[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and over
the past couple of days i've been asked
a lot about the nvidia shield tablet now
if you've seen any of the ads or if you
know anything about this it's basically
a gaming tablet a lot of people are
buying this specifically for the gaming
features and it's really good at that
but if you know me i'm really not much
of a gamer at all i don't play that many
games on my phone or tablet
but i didn't want to ignore this just
because i don't game so i decided to
check it out i picked it up anyway and
i've been using it a lot and turns out
when you take away a lot of the gaming
features and a lot of the stuff that
it's really good at for gaming it just
becomes uh an 8-inch pure android sort
of a nexus 8 kind of tablet so this is a
short video just going over the stuff
that you'll get on this tablet if you
don't game kind of proving that it's a
good tablet even without those awesome
features let's take a look so first of
all this shield tablet is made by nvidia
and besides all the awesome accessories
it works with and all the other cool
gaming tricks it has it has some pretty
beastly specs so it's packing nvidia's
latest and greatest k1 chip inside so a
2.2 gigahertz quad core processor 192
core gpu
2 gigabytes of ram 16 gigs of storage
and all the rest of the hardware is
geared towards showcasing that new k1
chip in fact that's really what this
whole tablet is all about so nothing too
flashy going on with the design it's
pretty compact it's got a pretty solid
weight to it a bit heavier than the
nexus 7 and just small enough that i can
hold it with one hand although i guess
most people will two-handed since it is
bigger than the nexus 7. but i gotta say
the build quality is pretty decent again
it's not the best build in the world but
you can see it's it's solid it's got a
pretty standard array of ports headphone
jack usb and hdmi on one side with a
speaker port and the other speaker port
on the other side and speaking of
speakers
yes this is one of a few tablets
just a few with front-facing speakers i
probably said this when talking about
just about every device with this but it
really should be standard especially in
tablets where you have all this space to
work with
i mean this isn't even a premium priced
tablet it's pretty mid-range and these
speaker drivers really aren't even that
good but they're still miles better
sounding than anything else with
back-facing speakers and you gotta love
that for media and of course you can see
inside that left speaker grille
is the front-facing camera it has a
5-megapixel front-facing camera and a
5-megapixel rear-facing camera both of
which are actually pretty good quality
but i don't think you should be using
them much anyway so really my only
complaint with the shield hardware is
just the buttons the power and volume
buttons they're pretty awful they're
really stiff and have almost zero travel
so they're a pain to use and i've been
using this tablet for weeks and i still
can't even change the volume without
picking up the tablet and looking at it
so the buttons are my only gripe so
anyway this tablet is clearly meant for
gaming and i almost feel bad not talking
about all these gaming features because
they're totally badass there's a
wireless controller there's dedicated
software hub and everything but like i
said i'm not a gamer and i wouldn't know
best about that so i'm actually going to
leave a link or two right below that
like button to videos that do a good job
of showcasing these gaming features but
for me this is an android 4.4 tablet
running almost pure stock android with a
few nvidia improvements and i really
like that i put the google experience
launcher on here and not only does it
feel really familiar and comfortable but
because it's stock android with no skin
and that beastly nvidia k1 everything is
fast fluid and smooth and the k1 really
shows off here even when you're just
doing regular multitasking or web
browsing
it's not a super high resolution display
so you're not pushing a ton of pixels
it's a 1080p 8 inch display so it's
pretty sharp but again the panel is just
mid-range it's a little on the warm side
it's just it's really about showing off
the nvidia k1 and it's just killing it
and just to make sure it wasn't just me
giving stock android too much credit i
fired up an application that honestly on
any other android tablet lags and
stutters and drop streams like crazy and
that's google earth a very old app but
you've probably experienced yourself i
opened it up here on the shield tablet
and the k1 handled it like a boss almost
zero dropped frames beautiful fluid
movement might actually finally be the
first android tablet that i can showcase
this app on and it doesn't lag and
stutter and crash so i guess it's kind
of crazy that google earth has remained
a benchmark for so long
so yeah with this awesome graphical
performance since nvidia is doing such a
good job with that of course using a
tablet with general everyday use is very
smooth you get fast performance it's
kind of kind of what you look for when
you're buying a tablet and this
basically nails it now there are a few
additions nvidia has thrown in again
mostly for gaming but some of the stuff
is pretty cool one of them i guess this
is the most major
is the stylus yes they added a stylus to
the back of this tablet something you
won't find on a nexus but it is a pretty
advanced stylus so when you remove it
you get a couple of stylus ready apps
you can choose to launch and the really
impressive one here is nvidia dabbler
it's made just for the shield i guess
nvidia just made this for this new
device and it uses and recognizes the
shape of the stylus it's like a felt tip
pen
and it kind of
rocks it's awesome it has this really
detailed precise watercolor effect if
you choose to use that brush a whole
bunch of different brush effects i mean
i felt like i could mess with this thing
all day until i legitimately create
works of art like this
all right i'm kidding that one came
pre-loaded but the stylus recognition is
definitely advanced as anything you'll
find on any you know ipad or any other
tablet
okay another thing nvidia has added to
the stock android experience was some
performance modes and i
really couldn't even tell the difference
i didn't look behind the scenes of what
it was doing to the cpu but again the
main purpose of the show off to the
nvidia k1 so they added those modes to
be able to change how that throttles
they also added hdmi settings since
there's a mini hdmi port and of course
settings for any controller you might
have added but again probably nvidia's
dedicated shield wireless controller for
gaming because all these features are
for gaming
and all the stuff is built right into
android settings so very conveniently
tucked away where you know you can find
them when you want to look for them
there's also in the quick settings
a toggle for full screen mode which is
basically android 4.4 is immersion mode
but full time for the entire operating
system like on demand so i guess if you
just hate seeing the notifications or
you just need to force a full screen
game to happen you can do that
so yeah really this tablet is full
featured it's packed it's legit i've
enjoyed using it over the nexus 7 mostly
for the front-facing speakers because
again i love hearing a sound move across
your face as the image moves across the
screen that kind of stuff you just can't
get with rear-facing speakers
and it makes media so much better and
tablets are really all about media if
you're gaming or watching a video or
whatever you're doing
uh and you know if you're gonna look for
the software updates over in nexus i
have faith because the nvidia shield the
og shield actually got quite a few
updates on the software department so
that's a good sign for this new tablet i
think they'll also get a few software
updates maybe see android l soon and you
know what those rumors of an 8-inch
volantis nexus tablet with front-facing
speakers we've all been dreaming about
you know even if that doesn't happen
this will always be an option and it's a
pretty good one props nvidia keep it up
thanks for watching guys and i'll talk
to you in the next one peace